In Windows, when you want to create
access to a file or a folder that can be
available across the network, we refer
to that as a Windows share. You are
sharing that information. And it could
be a file, a folder, a printer, or any
other resource that you can access
across the network. If you want to
access a share that's on another
computer on this network, you would map
a drive letter to that share. You'll
find the option to map that drive from
inside of File Explorer. You can also
map this drive from the command line
using the net use command. File Explorer
will show you all of the shares
available on a remote device. But if you
would like to administratively hide that
share from the rest of the network, you
simply include a dollar sign at the end
of the share name. So a share such as
admin dollar sign is a share that exists
on this computer and the share name is
admin. But if you look at it inside the
Windows user interface, that share will
not appear on a list of available shares
on that computer. This does not prevent
somebody from accessing that share if
they know the name, but it does prevent
it from showing up in a pull down menu.
And if you would like to see all of the
shares that have been configured on a
local machine, you can do this from the
computer management utility under the
shared folders option, and it'll list
all the shares on that
device. Here's File Explorer on my
computer. You can see I have a number of
devices and drives that are mapped. Some
are local on this machine, such as my C
drive and my D drive. But notice that I
do have three network locations that are
labeled as X drive, a Y drive, and a Z
drive. To connect to another share on
the network, you can use the three dots
at the top and use the option to map a
network drive. This will bring up a
dialogue box that allows us to specify
what drive letter we would like to use.
I have a lot of available drive letters
that I could specify. And then you can
either browse the network to see what
shares might be available on another
device or if you know the folder name,
you can specify it inside of this
dialogue box. You can choose the option
to reconnect to that share each time you
sign in. And you can also connect using
a different set of credentials than what
you are currently signed in as on the
current machine. And once you finish
using that drive, you can use those
three dots again and choose to
disconnect that network drive from your
file
explorer. With all of these different
devices sharing folders and files and
having printers available across the
network, we need to think about how to
secure all of these devices. And we also
need to think about how to organize all
of these devices. If you're on a network
at home, you can collect all of your
devices together into one logical group
known as a Windows workg groupoup. Every
device is a standalone system, but you
can connect them all together to have a
single name or a single logical
description, but everybody in that workg
groupoup maintains their own set of
usernames and passwords. This means that
a username and password you would use to
connect to a printer on one device might
be different than the username and
password that you use to share a drive
on a different device. This can really
complicate the process of keeping track
of usernames, passwords, and other
credentials. To be able to consolidate
everything into one single group of
credentials, you might want to use a
Windows domain. This is the common
configuration for a business or
enterprise where they want to
consolidate all of these usernames, all
of the devices, and all of the available
resources into one single view. This
means you only need to remember one set
of user credentials, and you don't need
to have a different login for every
individual device on the corporate
network. This also means that your IT
support team can go to one central place
to manage all of these users and all of
these devices, which is incredibly
useful when you have hundreds or even
thousands of devices that you need to
manage. You can view information about
work groups and domains from the system
applet. You can access that applet from
the Windows settings or from the control
panel. This will show you all of the
configurations for this device,
including the device name, and it will
tell you if this device is connected to
a Windows work group or if it's in a
Windows domain. You can choose the
option for domain or workg groupoup to
get more information about its current
settings. Here's my Windows settings.
I've selected the system category, and
you can see under the about option, I
have a listing of what this device is
set to. But if I click domain or work
groupoup, it will pull up a separate
window that shows me information about
the computer name and what domain or
work group this might be connected to.
If I want to change the name of this
device or connect to a different domain
or a different work group, I can specify
that by clicking the change option,
changing the name of the device or
perhaps moving it from a domain to a
work group or modify information about
the domain that it's currently connected
to.
Later on in this training course, we'll
talk more about Active Directory and how
these domains can help you manage the
process. For the meantime, keep in mind
that all of this information is stored
in a central distributed database on
your network described as an active
directory domain services database. You
often see this used in a business or an
enterprise, but because it requires a
separate server, we don't often see
Active Directory or domain services
being used in a home environment. If you
are in a business environment, then
you're usually connecting to this
Windows domain and you're using that as
your central administration point. So,
when you need to add a new user or
remove a user from the network, it's all
done inside of Active Directory. These
directory services also allow us to set
policies for all of these users and all
of these devices. So, if you need to
make changes to Windows configuration
inside of a user's laptop, you can do
that centrally using Active
Directory. If you'd like to connect a
computer to this Active Directory
network, we first need to make sure that
we're using the right edition of
Windows. We can't connect Windows to
Active Directory if we're using the home
edition of Windows 10 or Windows 11. we
need to make sure that we're using the
pro edition or better. Under the control
panel, we can choose the system option
or if we're using Windows settings, we
can simply use the system category and
choose the about option. From inside of
that view, we can choose to connect to a
domain or a workg groupoup. And we'll
need to make sure that we have the
proper credentials to be able to add
this device to our active directory
domain. Once we click domain or work
groupoup, it will bring up a dialogue
box that shows us that computer name and
what work group it might be connected
to. But in this case, we would like to
move it from the work group that it's
currently on to a domain. So, we'll
choose to change this information. And
it will ask us to input the credentials
required to connect to this Active
Directory domain. Once our username and
password is added and we've added the
domain name, we can click next and it
will connect this computer to the
domain. From that point on, anytime
someone logs in, they'll be logging in
with the centralized Active Directory
domain
credentials. If your Windows computer is
physically connected to a printer, you
have the option of sharing that printer
to everybody else who's on the network.
You can do this very easily inside of
your printer properties or inside of the
Windows settings. You can choose
Bluetooth and devices and then choose
the option under the printer to
configure the printer
properties. On my network, I have a
number of different printers configured,
but I'd like to share this Brother
printer that's at the top of the list.
If we'd like to share this printer, we
can select the printer properties. This
will bring up a separate dialogue box
for the properties. And within this
dialogue box, there is a tab for
sharing. Here you can choose to share
the printer. You can select the name of
the printer. And if someone now wants to
connect to this printer, all you have to
do is make sure that's checked. Click
okay. And now your printer is available
on the network.